[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez Mateo conmigo en
el estudio Rosa bienvenida buena mañana
de martes y repasamos entonces la
bienvenida a Richi es una que una prensa
británica e internacional como Primer
Ministro de Reino Unido precisamente
empezamos en su territorio con de
Independencia y el final Times Buenos
días Raúl exactamente hemos empezado
seleccionando estas dos portadas porque
ejemplifican muy bien un poco los dos
ángulos o sea de lectura de esta llegada
de Richi es una como viendo decías al
frente del ejecutivo británico por un
lado de independent hace una crítica muy
clara y es que dice sunat se convierte
en Primer Ministro sin un solo voto y
por otro lado el final Times por el
contrario celebra en cierto modo esta
llegada diciendo prometió afrontar el
profundo desafío económico no del país y
que eso suscitó una reacción positiva de
los mercados Rosa bueno precisamente
está no en línea el diario es sí Raúl
Pero si te parece vamos a todavía
ahondar un poco más en las aportadas
británicas porque de Times de Guardian y
el Daily telegraph coinciden en elegir
la misma cita de rifish que pronunció
frente a sus colegas del partido
conservador británico cuando fue
oficialmente elegido como líder de la
formación y por lo tanto también como
Primer Ministro del Reino Unido y él
dijo que el partido se debe unir o Morir
al menos electoralmente no porque se
parece bastante Claro que sí fracasa
regizuna que al frente del ejecutivo del
Reino Unido el partido conservador al
menos entraría en un coma electoral
importante viendo las encuestas no
frente a esta gran ventaja que le dan al
partido laborista si hubiera elecciones
ahora mismo y Esta es una de las razones
por las que viene el partido conservador
está haciendo tan reacio a convocar unas
elecciones generales como pide gran
parte de la sociedad por otro lado hemos
querido mencionar algunos de los puntos
en que estas tres cabeceras y gran parte
de la prensa británica coinciden en
destacar de la figura del que ya es el
Primer Ministro del Reino Unido tras
jurar su cargo frente al Rey Carlos III
básicamente
señalan que con 42 años es el Primer
Ministro más joven que ha tenido el país
en dos siglos por otro lado que es el
primer no blanco no una cosa pues que ha
sido titulares alrededor del mundo y por
otro lado que es el más rico del
parlamento y se estima que su patrimonio
junto al de su mujer que es hija de
narayana murci quien es a veces
calificado como el Bill Gates de la
India Pues que este patrimonio es
superior al del propio Rey no por otro
lado en de Guardian hemos querido
destacar la opinión del abogado y
escritor hashimohamed que Precisamente
en relación al hecho de que sea el
primer no blanco al frente de Downey
Street dice que es una victoria para
representatividad de los británicos
asiáticos pero que no representa tampoco
a la mayoría de hijo de inmigrantes no
como son los padres de Richie sunat que
fueron inmigrantes Pero que el perfil
del Primer Ministro se aleja mucho de la
historia de la mayoría de personas en
esta situación en el Reino Unido para
citar algunas de las cifras su colegio
valía 43.000 libras al año luego él fue
a Oxford a estudiar política filosofía y
economía y luego a Stanford donde hizo
un máster en administración de empresas
y por eso mismo dice que es una perfil
digamos que tampoco es una figura
progresista entre otras cosas se ha
declarado completamente favorable a la
política de deportaciones a Ruanda e
incluso se dice que es más rico que el
propio reino Carlos efectivamente como
comentábamos rosa en esa línea Ahora sí
va el diario.es exactamente que también
lo califica así joven millonario consejo
de inmigrantes hindú y abstemio también
para Pues saber algunas otras cosas de
este nuevo jefe del ejecutivo británico
y dice que es Euro escéptico convencido
desde adolescente Y qué opina de su
elección el induston Times Pues a medios
indios han celebrado no el hecho de que
Richie sunat llegara a liderar el
gobierno británico porque aparte de ser
el primer no blanco también es el primer
hombre con y la primera persona con
raíces indias no Y también hindú
declarado en llegar a esta posición de
poder celebran que coincida con la
festividad de Wally no la festividad
hindú pero también destaca lecciones que
India debe aprender No dicen la
importancia de elegir una persona de una
minoría en relación no a la isla
homofobia que profesa narendra modi y su
partido bjp vamos a la prensa fuera de
Inglaterra el National de Escocia y el
belfase telegraph de Irlanda del Norte
exa recordemos que the National es un
partido independentista escocés y que
vemos no en su portada que titulan de
forma pues muy clara ahora dejen escoger
a la gente que diga lo suyo no y por
otro lado tenemos a la ministra
principal de Escocia Nicola storgeon que
le dice a sunat que busquen legitimidad
de los votantes y por otro lado del
belfast telegraph dice que pronto va a
tener Regis una que gestionarte más
complicados respecto al protocolo de
Irlanda por favor nos hemos hablado de
los tablones británicos exactamente muy
rápidamente de San dice la fuerza está
contigo Richie que ganó la guerra de las
Galaxias de su partido metro por otro
lado dice primer Primer Ministro
asiático no sabemos si de una forma un
poco cruel porque claramente no es
asiático no como lo comentan el ese
europeo nació de hecho en Reino Unido y
en otros periódicos sí que lo llaman
digamos con raíces asiáticas bien en
todo caso dice el metro Here Comes de
sunat haciendo como un juego de palabras
con el here utilizan Este título de The
Beatles por otro lado Daily mail titula
Un nuevo amanecer en Reino Unido tras
semanas tras semanas de Caos la lucha la
contraofensiva Tori empieza aquí o el
Daily stark con un tono más humorístico
vemos este calendario en el que en el
mes de octubre pues pone a sunat y se
pregunta si llegará a final de mes y
finalmente Raúl en la prensa
internacional simplemente queríamos ver
que la misma foto se repite y también
los mismos titulares desde el país al
New York Times pasando por la nación de
Argentina o el global Times de China
Rosa como siempre Muchísimas gracias más
mañana con revista de prensa